they want us to feel like animals
because they blocked our cities the
biggest cities in ukraine and uh they
blocked and and uh because they don't
want our our people to get some food
water yesterday for example children i
don't know if you if you know the
children in mario was uh the child was
dead
yes you know that that that is the idea
of
of this operation or or i don't know how
house putin's
telling about it so that the idea
to you
you could do do with ukrainians animals
but but we are not
so how do you stop it are you going are
you prepared to do a deal you've said
you're happy to talk we can't stop alone
all this
no it's it's it's
only if
the world will unite
around ukraine around uniting around
ukraine they're not they're still it's
still very slowly it's still very slowly
but you can feel it only when you are
here because the people from europe or
usa it's far from ukraine it's far from
the heart of this tragedy and and you
you can't see you you can't understand
the details because you are not fighting
here and i understand why and i don't
want them to fight
but these countries can help can unite
because we can't speak about the close
the
i'm sorry that i'm speaking again and
again about this problem but we spoke
about children hospitals etc and you
know the the the
number of this
child deaths and and
and
so
we are speaking about closing the sky
you can't decide
to close or not to close
you can't decide if you are united
against the nazism and this terror you
have to close
not me don't wait me asking you
several times a lot million times close
the sky no you have to phone us
to our people
who lost their children and say sorry we
didn't do it yesterday one week ago we
didn't
push
putin we didn't speak with him a lot we
didn't found
find the dialogue with him we we we did
nothing and it's true yesterday
the world did nothing i'm sorry but it's
true
the british prime minister as a number
of other
world leaders say if they do that if
they close the sky that is that could
exacerbate and make the situation even
worse if they provide if they allow
poland to provide you jets on and
station it on nato land that will make
it worse what would you what
what does it mean
so the first question is rhetoric and we
we don't need rhetoric questions and
answers we have to have contracted
things so it would be was for whom
for our families
no
for whom
for them
no who knows nobody knows
but but we know exactly that now is very
bad
and in future it will be too late
and believe me believe me if if it's
prolonged this way yes you will see
they will close the sky
but will lose millions of people